yeah welcome to this video I really
played c4 on video let's do that now
this is some um again had an entire Slav
line with III not playing default and
here this is one of the ideas what does
blackguard doing now to defend the beep
on I think black needs to take on f3
yeah can take now here I hope this is
working it should be this is the whole
idea okay so we have her position well
I've got an extra point but he's got
some development I want to prevent
tonight before I hope I can't afford
this temple yeah maybe here gaining a
temp 1 on yeah gaining a temple in a way
because I've not sure you can allow the
Queen trade okay if you place a six
Queen a4s another temple on the bishop
should I yeah let's play that and then
castles you cannot play Bishop h 5 ER
this is quite nice
mmm coming to g5 does this yeah maybe I
think he needs to take now Oh is giving
me just happen yeah does he really want
to Castle long ma'am maybe maybe it's
not not completely completely out of
this world okay so play d4 first d for
Bishop t2 trying to I mean I cannot
castle long at the moment and cancelling
short it's not what you wanted for all
them
I can you can casa I mean this is some
compensation he's got quite decent piece
play he really wants me to take yeah I
can take and longer sounds don't know
can you g 8 c's on g2 well maybe just
just start back g5 I can take I hope
Bishop e7 there's screen g3 Queen g3
Bishop g6 though okay then I need to
take not much choice okay look in a 2g
two yeah it's not really it's not really
great to be honest this looks dangerous
ok I want to get the Queen back vmc
three this is why i give up the spawn
book g8 Quincy three and also the
specialists lodged
come in f6 may be getting out of this
temple I am I'm thinking about bishop d
2 group c 1 trying to attack myself on
the c line seafoam
okay you see threatening to take
probably yes roop g6 quincy 3g three key
of g three looks like an invitation to
sacrifice chief for Butchie one I don't
know that he's got definite compensation
Oh doesn't look too great
yeah this sort of he's blundering a poem
but getting some compensation is really
happening frequently in blitz games so
it's really just a pawn pawn down at the
beginning but this is already really
tricky oh but this I don't know isn't
yeah yeah okay let's take you first I
mean need to do this anyway I was so I'm
not quite sure that this is really great
look see one looks you on
and no just Queen f7 maybe it's not bad
okay take this all kinds of stuff
hanging and if it takes two nite f7
night h6 many pawns really
doesn't he need to take a g5 with the
idea you should cleave form
this could could also be just nonsense
to be honest it's a nice little trick
but yeah is it helping me much take with
the poor now of six and threatening h7s
is a threat okay
yeah far too complicated playing this in
this little time
and from the good of tape later mukuro
p.m. time warning
check
check
check aah chak chak yeah typical primo
nonsense at the end rave it's just a
crapshoot with no time on the clock yeah
I have no idea what's happening there g5
was probably really bad playing for this
trick this should be should be really
great for white here just just a normal
muth keeping the spawns and checked
there for ya now the computer actually
assesses this is completely winning with
g5 coming I have too many pawns I've got
six pawns and this is all working nicely
together this seems to be good as well
but it's not oops it's not as convincing
yeah here it wants to play a forum has a
stronger and here this is probably it's
still good for watch with F for the
whole not with this i blundered i
blundered h6 of course yeah and this
service is good for black who create
wins everything winds but this this is
now I'm good again for wide yeah okay
it's a blitz game 20 seconds on the
clock is more like a bullet game I hope
it was at least thrilling but it wasn't
great chess but at least were thrilling
at the end thanks for watching